so in the last 24 to 48 hours we were
told that despite having coronavirus
donald trump plans to be
at next week's debate with joe biden
which would be the second presidential
debate scheduled for thursday donald
trump however said this morning
that he's bailing out on the second
presidential debate with joe biden
and will not participate after the
commission on presidential debates
decided that because of health
recommendations in light of donald trump
being a coronavirus super spreader those
are my words not the words of the
commission on presidential debates they
decided to move debate number two
to a remote debate rather than do it in
person
uh frank farenkopf who's the head of the
debate commission
told cnn they made this decision
themselves it wasn't a decision made
with the presidential candidates but
they made it based on recommendations
from the cleveland clinic which advises
the cpd
on health related issues in light of
coronavirus the statement put out by the
cpd
says that quote the second presidential
debate
will take the form of a town meeting in
which the candidates would participate
from separate remote locations well
donald trump
does not like it he was interviewed this
morning
by fox business host maria bartoromo
trump says he's feeling great and he
will not do a debate
via remote teleconference or video thank
you so much for being here
uh first question is how are you feeling
how is the first lady feeling this
morning
she's feeling good i'm feeling good
really good
i think perfect and uh we're ready to go
i'm ready to go accept the quarantine
situation that you have for a little
while after you
get tested or whatever the procedure is
but i'm ready to do i'm looking forward
to doing the rallies
i heard that the commission a little
while ago changed the debate style
and that's not acceptable to us i beat
him easily in the first debate
according to the polls that i've seen
but i beat him easily
i felt i beat him easily i think he felt
it too he wouldn't answer any questions
and he had the
protection of chris wallace all night
long it was i thought i thought chris
wallace was a disaster
but i beat him in the first debate at
the second debate we have a never
trumper as a host but
that's okay because i beat him in the
second debate also
and uh but i'm not gonna do a virtual
debate
so you're not so mr president you're not
gonna do it because the cpd
the commission on presidential debates
announcing this morning
that the second presidential debate will
be virtual are you saying you're not
gonna participate no i'm not going to
waste my time on a virtual debate that's
not what debating's all about you sit
behind a computer and do a debate it's
ridiculous
and then they cut you off whenever they
want trump seemingly at the end they're
admitting what this is really about
they can cut you off whenever they want
which donald trump doesn't want because
his strategy
is to just keep talking most importantly
keep
interrupting joe biden speculatively the
idea is that
trump believes maybe accurately that
constantly interrupting joe biden
will uh work will wreak havoc
with joe biden struggling with a stutter
his whole life
and that it is really you're not arguing
the issues when your idea is to just
keep
interrupting the other the other
candidate and now it starts to get wacky
where maria bartoromo
just can't control trump and we're going
to look at this in the next segment but
listen to this
uh i have a host who i always thought
was a nice guy but i see he's a never
trumper you know came out that he's a
never trumper
uh we do have some of them maria believe
it or not because they don't like to win
uh and uh so but i'm not doing i'm not
doing reverse
they didn't even tell us about the
debate when farrenkov was asked about
trump not participating
he said that it's totally trump's right
there there is no law
requiring a presidential candidate to
debate
uh frank farenkov said that in 1980
jimmy carter
refused to participate in the first
debate later participated in the second
debate
and the commission essentially saying
it's up to the candidate to decide do
they want to debate or do they not want
to debate
so as of right now and forgive me if
this has changed
it's possible the commission will change
their plan it's possible trump will
change his mind anything could happen
but as of right now
debate two is scheduled to be remote and
donald trump
will not participate in that second
debate and
it's amazing how everything has come
back
you know we talk about projection from
the from the trumpists and how
all of these things they accuse others
of are things they are doing themselves
for months now trump has been saying
biden will bail
don jr others saying biden's going to
find a way out because biden just can't
do it
and it's actually donald trump who has
been the first to say
i'm not going to participate in a debate
i don't really know how much it will
hurt him listen the other reality is the
first debate really hurt trump
trump's polling fell off a cliff
uh the day after the first debate we
started to see
a rapid ascent for joe biden and a rapid
decline for donald trump
so it almost might be better for trump
not to debate
from the standpoint of not doing even
more damage by participating it's
certainly true
that not given the chance to interrupt
constantly which maybe trump wouldn't be
given if indeed the debate was done in a
remote format
it could be even worse for donald trump
so uh maybe he will end up participating
it's also conceivable that the cpd
will come to some agreement that there
was an idea thrown around
that they would move the debate outdoors
and have sort of a big
covered area where it's outdoors
and socially distanced with plexiglas i
still think it's
conceivable that in the next day or two
somebody proposes that and they say
given that we've been able to move the
debate outdoors and
account for this that and the other
thing that they'll do it in person again
it could happen it might not there might
be no second debate
i don't know how it's all going to go
does it turn into a joe biden town hall
if donald trump simply doesn't
participate or do they cancel the event
altogether
i don't know but next i want to look at
some other clips from this interview
that trump did this morning
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video